hey guys Benjamin's back here thanks for
tuning in so I'm just doing a quick
portfolio review for a Nasir I believe
is how you pronounce it I'm gonna do
just the desktop and the mobile version
of it just give my first impressions on
the overall responsiveness some of the
animations the font the layout etc etc I
think I'm also going to go ahead and
reviews his social media presence as
well
just as a little added bonus you know
hopefully he appreciates that yeah he
had reached out to me on Twitter I
introduced him to the code career org
discord community which you can just get
to by going to code career org slash
discord and in there he got some decent
feedback from one of our admins alex and
who also did getting a little bit of
feedback from me so anyway without
further to do let's go to Diamond so a
first right off the bat he has a nice
introduction so that's hi I'm the seer
let's see okay dig that
I love performance as much as expert
that I tried to be my best to create UX
rich performance websites and web apps
okay I suppose the only thing I see here
is if if you're gonna from this here is
going to you know capital gates were
like each letter of each word is
capitalized then I would ideally apply
that role to anything that's four
letters are more so would capitalize
much and capitalized create personally
though I would I think I would prefer in
on my own website just to have
everything you know a standard case so
you just have like the eyes capitalized
and then all of the other letters under
here are lowercase I feel like that adds
a better contrast between the header
here and then the the sub header or
description because this is quite a bit
of text I would kind of regard it as a
description beside I just kind of like
to see that contrast personally but
overall good cool and it looks like you
have a nice nifty animation here when
you go ahead and hover over that take
that and it looks like it comes as a pop
up alright I like the pop up the font is
nice the overall layout here is great I
like the separation of colors think that
animation that's good I'll see you can
grab my CV find out more about me
alright just a quick look at this okay
cool kick going back well one thing I
might recommend is keep these well oh
excuse me on the second pod
I do actually like the color difference
of the footer here and the button
because it does cause the button stay up
first and out I was initially going to
recommend keeping these the same color
but I like what you did there I think
the one thing I would recommend is maybe
changing this font playing with it just
a little bit maybe making it a little
bit brighter you know a little bit more
of a like a whitish color just to make
your your key details stand out but at
the same time I also understand that you
want your core focus to be the user
clicking on the download button so I
don't know I think there's there's a
balance there and you just strike the
balance pretty well yeah I suppose
whichever way you're leaning like if you
want to make that information more
parents and then I would make it a
verdict brighter color if you want to
make it a little bit less distracting
and really focus in on the download
button then it would make the font there
down here a little bit smaller maybe
keep it the same color
you know just then that way it's not as
predominant is not pulling as much
attention away
from the download button excuse me if
that's the key focus that you want to
have but overall to dig it all right so
let's close that out now this is a nice
large check up it's gonna be nice large
chunk of text can't speak tonight
personally I kind of like to break
things up a little bit so if you have
like say three maybe four sentences I
would break that up into separate
paragraphs or personally I'm a fan of
one to two sentences per paragraph just
because for a readability people love to
kind of skim things and it just makes it
easier on the eye you know there's much
less reader fatigue but overall looks
good I think again on this I would
follow the you know a very similar
capitalized case as your description or
sub header here you know try to keep
this capital case so each letter of a
larger word is capitalized and then keep
this lowercase with the exception of the
start of every sentence yeah because
it's just it looks really weird to the
eye to the eye to see you know like you
looking web developer capitalized but
then there's like this is lower case
that's lower case that's lower case that
then comes back to these being upper
case just looks a little strange at
first glance so that that's one thing I
think I would address again love the
animation though only go ahead and click
that cool and that brings you right to
Twitter
alright and your skill set again
probably the same feedback in terms of
you know breaking this out making it
look a little bit more readable well one
the two sentences per paragraph again
same thing with the text you know
staying consistent with the capital case
that you have or a lower if you set up
[Music]
another thing you could do I do actually
like the overall readability of this
like just peppering in or we're putting
in your skill sets in text I like that I
like the dotting that you use for the
underlining maybe though I would write
like a paragraph or so about your skills
like right here and then kind of like
lists of your skills so like one two you
know like under that sound like it's
still here and let's go here and just
kind of break it up so that they're like
separate you know words and you know
maybe even had a an icon to some of
these skills like CSS sass Babel Redux
react those all have their own logos and
icons for those but you know overall
looks good I take a look at your work
okay so that just Scrolls down to there
at the bottom okay I'm just gonna scroll
back up to the about me yeah same thing
it recommended with previous texts see
now this this looks okay to the eye
because you know this is a couple of
sentences I think that looks decent and
it looks like you were you're consistent
about the thing capitalization on this
as well so this you have as capital
cases as you have it's lowercase that
looks good front-end back-end cool like
the graphics would probably try to
rewrite this a little bit just to make
it a little bit shorter try to bring it
down to maybe this much text
same thing with this keep them
relatively the same consistent length
and
I like that you right there askew be
center-aligned a lot of your text but I
personally feel like you would best
benefit from just having this as the
center Alliance to make it kind of
stylistic and draw the eye down to the
higher me button but then when it comes
to to this text I would probably make it
left aligned just so that it's easier to
read
same thing with skill set about me and
probably these blocks of code here maybe
I would leave this Center Alliance just
again because it's kind of a stylistic
you know like starting point but you
know it's just kind of personal
preference let's see then you also have
my work cool click on both of those okay
and the sections are work in progress so
I'm not going to you know really dig too
deeply into that I imagine you're
probably going to have like a couple of
Twitter like cards or you know like a
couple of blocks here for your different
projects so that's cool
okay and these are a couple of projects
that you just created that I'm checking
out okay so yeah I imagine you probably
use something like that down here love
this really nice drop shadow on these
items and same thing with this okay so
you developed some some decent UIs
and overall your user experience is
really good biggest thing honestly that
I can see is just the the text
throughout better than that it's a great
portfolio good use of color good use of
fonts and a good use of color contrast
and overall layout
alright so let's bring this up okay and
I think this is just a one pager so just
gonna bring you to each section I love
that animation by the way okay that just
brings that up and of course we have
contact cool I'm gonna just go ahead and
hit f12 on my keyboard ensure that this
is set to iPhone
to scroll back up to the top cool and it
looks like it is a mobile first design
yep everything looks consistent here you
probably did mobile first so I can see
why you would want to center Lang that
but I would probably still go with left
align on that sure
now skill said this was definitely where
it would come I think it handy to have
like I said one of the two sentences and
then kind of separate out some of your
skills into icons or something of that
nature just so it's not like a huge wall
of text I know on desktop
not only does top but on mobile when I'm
scrolling through things I don't want to
have to read it a giant wall of text
same thing with that but again overall
great job cool
whoa hey nice job man I really
appreciate you sharing this portfolio
with me I'm just going to go ahead and
hit f12 again and add a little bit more
value to you because this is only
running at about 12 minutes just going
to bring up a couple your social
profiles probably won't take a look at
Facebook just because I don't have a
Facebook account
[Music]
come on Twitter cool looks like you're
doing you know decent social engagement
you're posting things that are good
things that's a great way to market
yourself I think for these so one thing
that I would do though is look for
relevant hashtags that you can start
using because that's we're really going
to help you get additional exposure
exposure excuse me for you to one of
these so see for example you you paste
the Paris gonna be posted something like
this on Monday I'm go leaves the 31st
was on Monday when you see yeah excuse
me so you could do something like a
motivation Monday on that or let's see
today was Wednesday so you could do like
Wednesday wisdom on some of these other
posts and
- you know a bunch of other things like
maybe quotes hashtag quote or what have
you and then I hope get you a little bit
more exposure on Twitter you typically
want to strike a balance between the
amount of hashtags and the the overall
besides the content that you have but
since these are images you can pretty
much get away with using I would say
close to 10 hashtags and it wouldn't
really look too spammy just because the
content is large again if you were just
doing pretty much plain text without an
image or you know doing like a video
that only has like a little display link
on it and then you would want to kind of
shorten the amount of hashtags you use
to something more conservative I would
say like four maybe five just as a rule
of thumb but yeah overall looks like you
were retweeting people engaging and this
is just kind of a surface level analysis
but yeah so far it looks pretty good so
let me go ahead and pop over to your
LinkedIn okay would definitely recommend
connecting with more people would
definitely recommend using a
personalized photo and listing
unemployed maybe a list freelancer or
apprentice or something of that nature
just showing that you're making progress
on whatever you're interested in in
pursuing now in terms of you know like
self taught again I would probably
elaborate on that you know if you've
done things like free code camp or code
Academy go ahead and list those they
actually do have those as educational
institutions on LinkedIn and now perhaps
I'm not being I'm not able to see your
whole profile just because of some of
the settings that you have because we're
not connected on LinkedIn so that is a
possibility as well but yeah I would
definitely recommend if you haven't done
it to again set those institutions
maybe put in some volunteer work put in
some other projects that you've worked
on perhaps start writing some blog posts
or articles that you can include in here
and also include you know what you've
been working on because you had
mentioned that you're doing full stack
rails and react which is fantastic I
mean have you've been doing that that
definitely includes some projects and
some of those additional tools that is
on your portfolio site in here
well LinkedIn isn't the best to land a
job directly with someone it is
fantastic to connect you with recruiters
you know it's typically how I would say
I'd probably get maybe a fifth of my job
requests it's just through LinkedIn you
know technical recruiters through
LinkedIn so just the consideration but
not something you have to focus on but
yeah just want to say it was a pleasure
thanks again for sharing your portfolio
with me I'm excited to have the
opportunity and if you're watching and
you like this video and you'd like a
portfolio or a resume review feel free
to check out the link in the description
would be happy to provide that to you
for free with the little caveat of you
know I'm able to post it on my youtube
channel I'm able to repost it on free
code camp and other code instructional
YouTube channels as well just so I can
provide more value to people but I also
do have a private option if you want to
go ahead and do that I can do it
privately for you however I do charge
that well once again this is vengeance
pack just want to say thanks for
watching and hopefully I'll see you in
another video